erstmal er hat sich mir kommen wieder
auf unserem team mit ein paar minuten
verspätung übrigens auch die patches und
die mitglieder haben probleme mit dem
team gehabt aber wir haben sie jetzt
einigermaßen löst und für die pens und
die mitglieder gibt es nach diesem spiel
noch mal einen stream also erst mal
herzlich willkommen
super dass es jetzt endlich geklappt hat
verfluchte technik mein spruch dazu ist
computer sind auch nur menschen und wir
wollen heute irgendwann thema sprechen
zudem ich erstmal hier meinen alten
weggefährten
es wird ein bisschen warm und herzlich
begrüßen darf der eine oder andere weise
er hat mich vor einigen jahren sagt man
sich 14 2014 hier auf nutzung begleitet
also kurz nach dem start und wir haben
zum beispiel dieses sensationelle
alkohol video zum jahren gemacht
großartige erinnerungen ja und du weißt
mir in viele hier wollen wir nicht alle
bilder online gestellt haben das ist
auch gut so ja also herzlich willkommen
zu unserem thema stream und ich freue
mich über zahlreiche fragen die wir
haben wir haben vorher schon einige
gesammelt er in der community vor allem
unternehmen mit ihrem unternehmen und
den trails mitglieder haben jetzt
übrigens die einmalige möglichkeit hier
ganz spezielle e motion abzufeuern und
man erkennt übrigens an dem auge in den
verschiedenen
farbtönen wir haben jetzt glaube ich
bronze und silber wo wir dürfen nur noch
bronze erstmal an weil er ist in einer
woche nach einem monat kriegt man dann
den silber button
und da kommen schon eine menge fragen
rhein wo kümmert sich darum
weil bei mir sind sie weil ich hier zwei
bildschirme haben ziemlich klein und wir
wollen uns heute um den klimawandel und
die klimawende und die klimakatastrophe
es gibt ja viele schlagwörter wollen wir
uns darum kümmern weil heute ist ein
besonderer tag es geht weiter mit der
versammlung zum thema klimawandel in
bangkok und dort wird die der welt die
weltklimakonferenz in kattowitz im
dezember in polen vorbereitet und jetzt
schon ist klar was da in 2015 in paris
beschlossen worden ist hat wenig
konsequenzen gesorgt es wird wenig
gemacht und selbst wir hier in
deutschland die ja eigentlich mit ihrer
energiewende als vorreiter gelten ja wir
tun zu wenig wir erreichen nicht unser
klimaziele für 2020 so sieht es im
moment aus und ich habe vorhin schon mal
erwähnt
wir haben ja eigentlich die besten
chancen gehabt was einerseits tragisch
ist aber eben für den klimawandel war es
gut denn viele schmutzige industrien im
osten sind
wir haben einfach nicht mehr weiter
produziert weil sie ineffektiv franken
und das heißt eigentlich ist automatisch
durch den durch die deutsche einheit
haben wir sehr leicht gehabt die
klimawende hinzubekommen ja also das ist
unser thema heute und ich will als
erstes mal die eine positive nachricht
loswerden ich habe das ja schon
angekündigt in unserem heutigen video
und das ist wirklich ein bisschen
sensationell
man hat nämlich inzwischen hat sich
herausgestellt dass die co2 zertifikate
dazu führen dass die verstromung von
kohle immer teurer wird und ist so
aussieht dass das eine oder andere
kohlekraftwerke bald quasi von selbst
schließen muss weil der strom einfach
viel zu teuer ist
das hat ja vor einigen jahren wurde das
ja schon beschlossen dass co2 mehr co2
produziert muss dafür eine abgabe zahlen
und und zwar kann er aber mehr t co2 zu
produzieren so genannte co2 zertifikate
kaufen also von industrien die nicht so
viel co2 produziert und damit kann er
dann darf er dann mehr co2 in die umwelt
pusten aber dafür muss man eben teuer
bezahlen und für kohlekraftwerke gilt
dass die müssen eine menge geld dafür
bezahlen was die co2 in die umwelt
entlasten und das ist ein richtiger
markt diese zertifikate und da sind im
moment die preise die steigen erheblich
liegen glaube ich pro tonne co2 im
moment bei 30 euro aber dass mich nicht
darauf festlegen wir sind live da kann
ich nicht immer alles ganz entspannt
nach gucken also hat ein bisschen
verständnis wenn ich mich manchmal nicht
so genau festlegen
wir haben eine menge fragen zum thema
klimawandel klimakatastrophe klimawende
wände bekommen und ich will einige davon
beantworten weil wir schon zahlreiche
videos zu diesem thema gemacht haben und
so zu den meisten fragen habe ich
die antworten parat also das wird ein
stream her wo man sich wirklich
ausführlich über das thema informieren
kann und ich auch noch mal im vorhinein
mich mit diesen fragen mit einigen
fragen beschäftigt haben die hier
eingelaufen sind aber tatsächlich mit
vielen vielen fragen haben wir uns im
vorfeld schon beschäftigt ja und ganz
interessant ist das oder ich sage mal
eine wende in dieser ganzen geschichte
hat ja dieses jahr stattgefunden
zum ersten mal weil die komplette
nordhalbkugel der erde war das gab es
bisher noch nicht
und da hat dann selbst musik latif einer
der führenden forscher hier in
deutschland gesagt da kann man jetzt
nicht mehr verneinen dass das mit dem
klimawandel zusammenhängt das ist das
was wir immer vorher gesagt habe und das
ist wirklich eine schlimme katastrophe
denn wir haben es im video
heute zeigt alexander gerst hat am 6
august deutschland von oben fotografiert
und das war gar nicht gut aus nämlich
braun stadtgrün und ja und ich gehe
jetzt mal auf die fragen hier ein wenn
ihr weitere fragen hat
so kümmert sich darum schreibt die hier
fleißig rein so dass ich darauf
antworten kann und wenn er auch selber
informationen habt wenn er selber
was erfahren habt schreibt es auch ruhig
ein ist alles super spannend also wir
kommen mal sagen der ersten fragen wie
fortgeschritten sind die technologien um
ins klima einzugreifen
dazu muss man sagen da sind wir noch
ganz am anfang wir haben ja schon öfter
mal darüber berichtet dass es gibt ja
einen eine ich sag mal eine gruppe von
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die sich damit beschäftigen wie können
wir denn gezielt auch als menschheit
dagegen eingreifen
wir haben zum beispiel berichtet über
anlagen die co2 umwandeln können so dass
sie dann in gewächshäuser eingeladen
zwei aus der luft entnommen werden kann
dass sie dann in gewächshäusern oder zum
beispiel eingespeist werden kann damit
pflanzen aus diesem co2 wieder
sauerstoff machen können es gibt
möglichkeiten festen kohlenstoff aus dem
co2 so herzustellen dass in der luft ist
und so weiter und so fort aber wir sind
noch ganz am anfang und ob es dann
technologien gibt die wirklich auch
einsetzbar sind das ist dann die frage
wann man bei einigen vorschlägen zum
beispiel substanz in die atmosphäre
einzubringen um sonnenlicht zu
reflektieren
dann auch wieder so erheblich ein greift
in das in die erde oder in die welt und
das in einem maße wo man dann vielleicht
nicht abschätzen kann wie erheblich die
konsequenzen sein können an so einer
stelle sind wenn inzwischen und erfahren
dass an vielen ecken und enden wenn du
warst mein jahr das kann gerade auch
weil man sieht auf dem t-shirt nur nazi
und das soll natürlich nicht die
botschaft die heißt das doch mal vor
nazis raus aus den stadien das ist eine
aktion eines kleinen fußballvereins wo
einfach die nazis einfach zu viel ärger
gemacht haben
und natürlich gehören nazis auch nicht
im fußballstadion
weil ja sie eigentlich nur für ärger
sorgen und rassisten sind was natürlich
technologie enthalten ist und dazu
gehört und nazi zu sein und deswegen
nazis raus aus den stadien
dafür geht es auch und natürlich auch
für alles andere ja dann gibt es hier
eine frage zum thema programm da hat es
ja nicht so viel mit dem klimawandel zu
tun da geht es um die entfernung von
plastik und übrigens auch eine
mittelschwere katastrophe ist aber heute
nicht unbedingt unser thema mein
deutscher wald ist gäbe keinen menschen
der machten thema wandel
christoph sieht das als das was denn nun
erst ein deutschlehrer hat
offensichtlich geringe anderem von
wissenschaft das werde ich auch das
werde ich jetzt ist er immer wieder
zurückkommen wissenschaft funktioniert
nämlich unabhängig von dem was ich oder
mo oder sonst jemand glaubt sondern das
ist ein relativ stringentes und
einfaches verfahren ich beobachte zuerst
einmal was zum beispiel ist wird wärmer
auf der erde so dann gucke ich woran
liegt das denn untersuchte verschiedene
dinge dann gibt es verschiedene
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftler
finden verschiedene thesen aufstellen
auch hypothesen genannt sprich ideen
woran das liegen könnte
so und jetzt hat man kanal um zehn ideen
jemals habe zu viel die heizung
eingeschaltet die sonne ist wärmer
geworden
co2 ist mehr geworden mehr geworden so
und jetzt überlegt man sich wie kann man
das ganze denn überprüfen sondern kann
ich mir zb ansehen kann gucken wir haben
sich die sonnenflecken dort entwickelt
ich kann gucken hat die heizung stärker
angestellt ich kann gucken welchen
einfluss hat co2 auf das klima ist es
mehr geworden und mehr deutlich mehr als
90 prozent aller studien und auch
überprüfungen dieser studien sind
draufgekommen dass co2 ist gestiegen
in der atmosphäre und das ist zwar nur
einen ganz kleinen bruchteil der
atmosphäre aber dieser bruchteil hat
sich dramatisch vergrößert und dann hat
dann kommt die nächste stufe dass man
guckt woher kommt denn das co2 und so
weiter und so fort und unabhängig von
dem glauben den einstellungen usw
von den wissenschaftlern kommt man ganz
logisch dann zu ergebnissen und in dem
fall kann der deutschlerner ist einfach
kein wissenschaftler hat deutsch gerät
da hat er einfach von diesem thema
überhaupt keine ahnung dessen und
klimaforschung kam hat auf das ergebnis
das ist dass co2 ist ja auch logisch es
wird ohne ende co2 aus schornstein kann
man ja überall sehen und auspuffen
ausgestoßen und das ist das
forschungsergebnis ist ein
wissenschaftliches ergebnis es könnte
natürlich eine bahnbrechende studie in
zukunft geben die das gegenteil beweist
aber die chancen sinken
man muss sagen mit jedem tag es gibt
institute die sich darum kümmern und und
und die arbeiten einfach nach strengen
wissenschaftlichen maßstäben jetzt gibt
es natürlich das argument aber es gab
schon viele thesen sind widerlegt worden
oder studien ja in einzelne beispiel bei
spielen scheint dass immer mal wieder
der fall zu sein dass eine studie
irgendwas behaupten dann widerlegt aber
das genau der punkt es ist eine
hypothese wird widerlegt und beim
klimawandel gibt es inzwischen ich habe
die zahl nicht geladen kommt wirklich
tausende studien und und wieder
überprüfte studien und belegte
ergebnisse es ist einfach so der
klimawandel findet statt und er ist
menschengemacht da gibt es einfach
nichts dran zu deutschland weil es
wissenschaftlich ist und immer wenn
jemand sagt ja ich verbinde studie
gefunden oder hier hat einer das
hergeleitet dass es nicht so ist dann
war das ein ornithologe ein geologe und
so weiter also leute die von dem thema
keine ahnung haben und dazu muss man
wissen ich habe mal bin mal hat man
theorie fürs fliegen gelernt und ich
kann euch nur sagen wetter ist das
komplizierteste was es so ziemlich gibt
dagegen ist nötig ein fliegenschiss weil
das mit physik chemie biologie und eben
mathematik komplizierte formen druck und
so weiter eine rolle
deswegen sagen auch klimawissenschaft
ja immer wir sagen das thema voraus
nicht das wetter und deswegen ist es so
eine sensation dass mojib latif jetzt
gesagt hat nee also diese extreme
wetterveränderungen haben mit unserem
voraussagen für das veränderte klima zu
tun
so jetzt zwei solchen wenn ich dann mal
ganz kurz rein kraft um einen manchmal
der mikro bitte richtig hin weil das
versuchen gerade internet hört so geht
dann das herrliche sache und ein ganz
anderes treibhausgases co2 ein ganz
anderes wichtiges treibhausgas methan ja
es gibt sie die frage wo ist der
kritische punkt bei der methan
freisetzung im permafrost also ab
welcher menge ist der kipp punkt
erreicht von kipp punkten ist er immer
mal wieder die rede
ich fürchte wir haben in vielen
bereichen schon die die jeweiligen
tiefpunkte überschritten
beim permafrost haben jetzt das problem
dass diese blöden auftauen und das
enthalten
methan in die luft entweicht es gibt ja
auch den verdacht dass in den ozean das
methan was als methanhydrat in sehr
hohen tiefen und warum druck gebunden
ist entweicht wenn sich das wasser
erwärmt man kann das nicht sagen wo
wirklich ganz konkret der punkt ist das
wird im moment nur vermutet dass er
schon überschritten worden ist hat man
auch ein video für für drüber über das
thema oder vielleicht noch nicht wir
hatten noch nie einen klimawandel wir
wissen nur im moment ist es so dass er
schneller und schneller wird dass wir
die heißesten sommer die see in den
wetteraufzeichnungen gab in den letzten
jahren hatten mehr gibt es nicht als
gesichert wenn jetzt ich behaupten würde
wirtschaftler der punkt ist garantiert
überschritten also dann müsste er schon
gute beweise für haben ich vermute dass
es die nicht gibt
jetzt haben wir noch das thema
radioaktivität also ein atomkraft und
thorium da haben wir auch einen beitrag
darüber machte man thorium reaktoren die
tatsächlich aus
ein bruchteil des materials von thorium
unmengen an der gegner energie gewinnen
könnten das problem bei thorium
reaktoren ist wenn man damit tatsächlich
eine energiewende herbeiführen würde und
zwar weltweit würden auch
entwicklungsländer und länder die in
kriegerischen oder zumindest im
spannungs konflikten mit anderen ländern
stehen sehr leicht an atomwaffen geraten
und das ist der hauptkritikpunkt an
thorium deshalb also das ist jetzt meine
private meinung dass es keinen
wissenschaftlichen hintergrund sondern
ich halte das für gefährlich und bin
deshalb wie er einen an den ganzen
kernfusion war sowie gefahren deutlich
niedriger sind und die radioaktivität
deutlich niedriger ist das ist meiner
meinung nach die technologie der zukunft
hoffe ich
es wird jetzt im stream ganz oft hier in
den kommentaren gesagt auch dass zum
beispiel santhera viehzucht ist und ja
diese genau überbeanspruchung der erde
wir werden jetzt immer mehr wir werden
immer mehr nahrung brauchen jetzt ist
hier die frage werdet ihr auf das thema
viehzucht eingehen ja werden wir die
damit verbundenen probleme für das klima
und den menschen ja also viehzucht ist
ein riesenproblem das fängt alleine
schon damit an dass man unmengen an
wasser ich glaube für rund 16.000 liter
braucht um eben dass die nahrung zu
produzieren unmengen an gemüse und gras
und so weiter nahrungsmitteln für die
tiere um fleisch zu produzieren also es
ist ziemlich ineffektiv und achtung
jetzt ganz wichtige info also die
fleischproduktion produziert nicht so
viel co2 weniger erdöl industrie sondern
wie einer der erdölkonzerne also wie
exxon oder michelle also ist schon
erheblich groß und durch auch durch den
transport also nicht nur das methan das
durch den tier was die tiere sollen die
luft pusten was ja auch ein extremes
klimagas ist was allerdings sich
deutlich schneller als co2 wieder abbaut
aber sie produzieren hat eine menge und
fleisch ist mit sicherheit auch ein ganz
ganz großes problem und wir können
glaube ich auch da nicht so weitermachen
da gibt es ja auch noch mehr werden
durch monokulturen betrifft jetzt auch
fische in südamerika minen sind glaube
ich 20.000 lachs in die dort überhaupt
nicht hingehören sind aus einer
fischfarm ausgebrochen und das sind
raubfische und jetzt weiß man nicht wie
das ökosystem darauf reagiert also das
ist mit ganz vielen risiken verbunden
und problemen auch ich bin ja versuchen
mein fleischkonsum zurückzuhalten er ist
er mal vegetarisch ja kann ich nur
empfehlen und wird unser klima deutlich
verbessern aber die weltweiten falsch
produzenten rechnen bedauerlicherweise
mit einer höheren fleischproduktion
das heißt aber du siehst das jetzt auch
nicht als also sind entnervt das dass
man quasi komplett sagt man verzichtet
komplett auf tierische produkte ist ja
immer so dass was immer mal so gesagt
wird wenn die ganze welt wieder an wäre
wäre alles viel besser und also vegan
ist ein problem weil da muss man sehr
genau auf seine ernährung achten dass
das blut untersuchen wollen vegan
bedeutet dass man auch auf alle
tierprodukte wie milch und so weiter
käse verzichtet
da gibt wir sind einfach allesfresser
der mensch ist ein allesfresser sehr
muss darauf achten dass er darum seien
seine alle dinge die er so essen muss
zusätzlich bekommt da ist vegan
problematisch aber es ist tatsächlich so
würden die umwelt wahnsinnig schützen
wenn wir auf fisch und fleisch
verzichten würden auch die weltmeeren
dagegen ja langsam die fischer aus die
sind total überfischt das ist alles ein
sehr sehr großes problem und wir sollten
auf jeden fall vegetarisch essen vegan
weiß ich nicht vegetarisch wer auf jeden
fall das bessere mittel und ich kann
mich noch mal eine jugend erinnern da
hat man vielleicht 100 zweimal in der
woche fleisch gegessen heute es mir
jeden tag überall fleisch ja das gab es
früher so nicht und das ist schade
also es wird uns ist ein großes problem
ja dann haben wir hier noch was und zwar
geht es darum welche technik wird sich
in der mobilität so durchsetzen es geht
darum
wir werden von verbrennungsmotoren
wegkommen müssen wir sehen ja hier wir
werden von den autoherstellern brauchen
wieder drüber gemacht betrogen
sie sind für tausende tote jedes jahr in
europa fahren konnte ich dadurch dass
sie die abgase abgas grenzwerte nicht
einhalten und das ist ein großes problem
wir brauchen elektromobilität
da gibt es jetzt viele argumente der der
der wähnt sich der rucksack noch der
ökologischen rucksack der der
elektroautos ist aber bei weitem nicht
so groß wie von einem verbrennungsmotor
fahrzeuge sich an zb smart der nach
30.000 kilometern im in
anführungszeichen tatsächlich grünen
bereich ist also ist tatsächlich von
seiner öko bilanz deutlich besser als
ein auch erwarten wagen mit
verbrennungsmotoren also diese techniken
brauchen wir einfach damit wir mit dem
autoverkehr nicht weiter denkt immer
wandernden feuern
ich denke dass sich die batterie
durchsetzen wird und das hat gar nichts
mit dem besseren prinzip zu tun sondern
hat damit zu tun dass wir da schon so
weit sind die brennstoffzellen wurde ja
in den 70er und 80er jahren erforscht
dann hat man das aber fallengelassen und
dadurch ist man mit der brennstoffzelle
ist das verfahren mit dem man strom
durch wasserstoff erzeugt dass man in
einen tank füllt und das dann mit
sauerstoff reagiert und so energie
erzeugt und das geschieht in einer
brennstoffzelle und da ist die forschung
einfach viel zu langsam fortgeschritten
und die batterie technologie geht damit
ich sammer siebenmeilenstiefeln voran
von daher denke ich dass es die
batterietechnologie sein wird die müssen
halt haltbarer werden sie müssen
mindestens eine tagesreise
ich sag mal 800 kilometer reichweite
haben und sie müssen innerhalb von
möglichst wenigen minuten zu einem
erheblichen teil aufladbar sein aber das
geht ja in diese richtung und von daher
ich glaube im prinzip ist diese
technologie nicht der brennstoffzelle
überlegen aber
sie hat sie wird sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich durchsetzen also ein
bisschen wir kennen wer kennt es noch es
gab in den zoo um die 70er 80er jahre
wenn du zwei video-systeme video 2010
grundig und vas von jvc gc vor es war
deutlich schlechter als video 2000 hat
sich immer durchgesetzt weil die
marktmacht einfach größer war
und das wären wir wahrscheinlich die
batterie haben es gibt noch ein prinzip
problemen beim wasserstoff wasserstoff
wir kennen das von der graf zeppelin von
diesem unglaublichen unglück in
lakehurst ist extrem entzündlich das
heißt es müssen sehr hohe
sicherheitsanforderungen erfüllt werden
damit überhaupt mit dieser substanz
umgegangen werden kann und wir müssen
uns mal das periodensystem vor augen
führen dass ist dann ganz am anfang das
ist so ziemlich das kleinste nein es ist
das kleinste atom was es gibt deshalb
die fundiert ist also entweicht über das
kann eine stahl flasche tun und das ist
nach einem zeitraum ich kenne nicht den
genau das ist raus es geht einfach raus
ist nichts womit man wasserstoff in ein
gefäß füllen kann es gibt die
möglichkeit dass ich sage mal in
schwammartige strukturen abzuspeichern
entweicht es weniger stark aber das ist
das problem ist ja das ganze atom und
damit hat man ein großes eine große
herausforderung
ich würde dir gerade frage anschließen
wenn wir gerade schon wie ein verkehr
sprechen und zwar der ganze auf dem
wasser ozean kreuzer sind beweist man
die mega luftverschmutzer gibt es eine
praktische antriebstechnik die sie zu
grünen riesen macht ja ich würde sagen
segel
ich glaube es gibt nichts anderes weil
sie haben einen einen sehr großen
energiebedarf um vorwärts zu kommen
das wird mit ich glaube mit strom nicht
funktionieren
ja ich sehe wir verbrennen der moment
vor allem schweröl das ist so ziemlich
die letzte scheiß der übrig bleibt ein
zeichen beim grafen geräten von apple
ist als unsere matschie und die wird
dann verbrannt und hat umfasst ich für
rückstände und das ist natürlich
wirklich beschissen für die umwelt auch
da sind die zahlen irgendwie die sieben
größten konstanz stoffe produzieren so
viel dreck wie der ganze autoverkehr
das ist ein bisschen schief sie machen
schon umfasse ich viel dreck aber nicht
ganz so viel aber das ist ein extrem
großes und eine sehr große
umweltverschmutzung und da muss man auf
jeden fall
ich glaube wenn man dort schon
vernünftige brennstoffe verbrennen würde
ich meine so viele kreuzfahrtschiffe
gibt es auch nicht dann könnte das
wahrscheinlich unsere atmosphäre
aushalten andere als anderes thema als
im insight verkehr kam letztlich jemand
zu mir und sagte eigentlich sollten wir
also innerstaatlichen flugverkehr
abschaffen also hier in deutschland zum
beispiel von berlin nach köln und so
weiter ich fange übrigens nur noch zu
kindern deutsch fliege deshalb kommen
auch weil ich find's einfach viel
bequemer ich arbeiten schlafen sonst was
kann dauern vielleicht insgesamt mit zum
flughafen fahren einchecken
sicherheitscheck und so weiter und so
fort vielleicht ein stündchen länger
nachtrennen zum beispiel jetzt auch nach
münchen superschnell nach hamburg von
berlin super sowie so superschnell also
ich glaube auch das innerdeutsche
flugverkehr zum beispiel einfach
überflüssig das könnte man sich auch
sparen dann würden wir wahnsinnig viel
dreck verhindern denn die bahn fährt ja
immerhin mit grünem strom also auch was
gutes und wir hatten noch eine frage in
diesem zusammenhang da wollte ich noch
gerade drauf eingehen weil das genau was
man hier war das ach ja genau das ist
meine ganz wichtiges thema weil es immer
wieder diskutiert wird ja es wird ja
auch viel täter sie die brisanz in den
usa an anderer stelle es gibt gar kein
thema wandel
wir haben hier schreckliche unwetter
aber all das sind folgen des
klimawandels als auch die extreme kälte
ist eine folge des klimawandels also es
gibt zwei folgen generell wird es wärmer
auf unserem planeten sie eben komplett
warme nordhalbkugel jetzt im sommer und
die zweite folge es gibt mehr meter
extreme und effekt damit zusammen dass
aufgrund der erhöhung der temperatur es
geringere temperatur unterschiede gibt
gerade auf der nordhalbkugel kann man
das super beobachten oder
bedauerlicherweise beobachten und zwar
gibt es sogenannte jetstreams extrem
schnelle wende die sich um die achse
drehen
vielleicht können wir das sie jetzt mal
einen blenden er gleich quasi wenn ihr
wieder scharf gestellt
solch ein anderes t-shirt anziehen
die hostie wellen also hier unsere
jetstream genau
ja ja die jetstreams du weißt ja so
sieht das also aus die sechs teams und
diese die schlagen die wellen und diese
wellen
die werden immer stärker und dadurch man
sieht dass hier
es gibt wählen die von oben also vom
nordpol nach unten gehen es gibt wählen
die von unten also vom süden nach norden
gehen und die eine wellenbewegung bringt
kalte luft vom nordpol an den in den in
den süden man sieht es ja gerade über
den usa das ist eine typische situation
in dem extrem kalte luft werden das
letztes jahr im märz in blizzard in new
york mit unglaublichen schneefall die
flugzeuge konnten nicht mehr starten und
landen ich war selber dort das war
wirklich ziemlich heftig ja das ist die
eine folge und auf dem rückweg bringt
genau diese welle dann warme luft zum
beispiel in diesem fall richtung europa
ab und hier wird es wärmer und das
bedeutet einfach die kriegen waren sich
heftiges wetter ein anderer auch ein
extra anderes extrem da haben auch ein
bild so ist die ice
der rückgang des eises in der arktis das
ist auch ziemlich dramatisch wir können
das hier auf dem bild zeigen wie das in
den letzten jahrzehnten zurückgegangen
ist und da sieht man oberhalb von
russland war früher heiß und das gibt es
jetzt nicht mehr dort sieht man hier
links im bild auf der linken seite ist
noch über russland als auf der anderen
seite ist eben über russland kein eis
mehr das ist oberhalb von uns willkommen
jetzt zentral auf die auf den nordpol
und aus diesem offenen mehr verdunstet
jetzt viel mehr wasser das ist dunkler
als das weiße eis das heißt es werden
sich dadurch auch noch stärker auf das
wasser verdunstet und kommt hier halt
wieder durch die roste wellen eben 22
nach unten befördert mit tierischer
mit unglaublichen regenmengen an
deswegen regnet sie jetzt stärker in
europa also der klimawandel ist eben ein
wandel es heißt nicht grundsätzlich
erhitzung saß klimawandel thema
erhitzung das beispiel deutlich mehr
wärme und deutlich mehr unwetter das ist
so der kern des klimawandels und ja das
ist so noch mal ein ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt
ja und dann haben wir mal die frage das
ist auch ganz wichtig was spricht denn
für den menschengemachten klimawandel
und das ist wirklich ganz einfach
forschung das heißt die forscher und
forscherinnen haben einfach geguckt was
verursacht den klimawandel warum wird es
wärmer also erst mal was passiert da
wird es wärmer dann hat es geschätzt
wird wärmer dann haben sie gefragt was
ist der grund dann haben sie co2
gefunden
dann haben sie ein ruck woher kommt das
co2 können wir selber sehen aus
schornsteinen und damit war dann sehr
schnell klar der klimawandel des
menschen gemacht und das ist nicht von
der hand zu weisen und zwar insbesondere
weil das ist sich eine studie sind nicht
zwei studien sind hunderte und tausende
studien die das inzwischen auf die
unterschiedlichste art und weise
bestätigt haben und es gibt mit an
extremer sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit keinen anderen grund
für den menschengemachten klimawandel
dazu muss man sagen natürlich die sonne
hat unterschiedlich stark der
aktivitäten
es gibt auch natürliche
klimaschwankungen und so weiter und so
fort aber gar nicht mehr vorstellen das
kommt noch und ob und damit wird es
führt das zu wetterextremen die wir
bisher so auf der erde nicht hatten und
das sehen wir ja an denen ein oder
anderen stellen so was mich jetzt
interessieren würde
wir hatten schon co2 als thema und jetzt
ist ihr aber auch methan hat und jetzt
in frage wenn co2 so schlimm ist was
wieso ist es dann normaler bestandteil
der luft das ist ja nur das ist wie man
kennt es vielleicht von tomaten
da habe ich eine ganz tomaten denkt
jeder automat die symptomatik noch nicht
schlimm aber wenn man
kann in ihren mehr hat es gibt ja viele
dialysepatienten die aufgrund einer
nierenentzündung ihre lieben verloren
haben kann man sich mit einem kilo
tomaten bringen die sterben sofort wenn
sie ein kilo tomaten essen für uns ist
es kein problem wir haben ihnen die
bauern es ab das heißt es ist immer eine
frage der menge auch ich kann es kann
ich kann laut eure kann ich annehmen und
in einer ganz geringen menge kann das
positive wirkung haben oder arsen oder
keine ahnung es ist immer gift ist immer
nur eine frage der menge und das heißt
alles und zwar alles man kann sogar
wasser vergiftet und kriegen ich weiß
nicht ob du wusstest man kann so viel
wasser trinken dann bekommt man der
wasserrettung die wasserwehr für uns ist
dass das einfach durch das wasser gruppe
mineral so ich hatte doch was ich ja
gespült werden dass die dann fehlen
eines echten und stopps das heißt es bei
allem eine frage der menge alles ist in
kleinsten mengen je nachdem was ist eine
substanz ist kleinste mengen sind meist
viel größer als bei arsen kann es
durchaus sogar heilsam und gut sein
in der größeren menge ist alles
zumindest schädlich oder sogar tödlich
und das gilt für nahezu alle ganz
überfressen man kann also essen sei
nicht gesund aber kann sich über fast
tausend sachen man kann an alkohol
alkohol ist ja in geringen mengen sogar
gesund also in sehr geringen mengen und
in anderen banken ist es erheitern und
in noch mehr deutlich also von gift ist
immer nur eine frage der menge nicht die
substanz und wir haben zu viel co2 in
der luft und das ist schädlich für uns
und für zum klimawandel alles klar
ja was können wir tun ist hier noch mal
eine frage und da möchte ich jetzt auf
unsere infokarte hinweisen die hier oben
im bild ist wir haben eine petition
rausgesucht von greenpeace auf
change.org wo unsere kanzlerin an ihr
versprechen erinnert wird dass
hingegeben hat sie hat ja gesagt dass
sie
einen weg finden wird das die klimaziele
bis 2020 rund 40 prozent reduktion der
cs des co2 ausstoßes und das hat sie
versprochen im vorfeld der
bundestagswahlen und diese petition
erinnert sich an dieses versprechen es
eben bis 2020 einzuhalten und ihnen
nicht später und das ist auch wichtig
weil wir sind dazu in der lage
profitiert natürlich zum beispiel durch
die autoindustrie
wir sehen dazu in der lage das zu
schaffen und wir sollten dann mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen um anderen ländern
zu zeigen
auch ihr körpers und das muss man sagen
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist ein
hoch industrialisiertes land das heißt
hier gibt es umfasst viele fabriken
umfasst sich viele kohlekraftwerke haben
ja auch gerade das thema das heißt die
möglichkeit die sind hier beschränkt es
ist schwierig so in diesem erheblichen
umfang den co2 ausstoß zu verringern
erleichtern kommt natürlich hier die
wende im osten
der niedergang der industrie nation was
tragisch ist wenn die menschen ihre
arbeit verloren haben aber für das klima
eben diese
diesen vorteil hatte aber unabhängig
davon sind wir hin sehr industrialisiert
und es ist schwierig dieses ziel
einzuhalten aber wenn wir es nicht
schaffen wir es dann schaffen und dann
muss man immer wieder sagen es kann doch
nicht sein dass wir die erde und damit
die menschheit aufgeben nur weil wir
keine ahnung nicht zu bequem sind ja und
diese bequemlichkeit dann zum tod dieser
zivilisation führt und man darf nicht
vergessen es ist ja schon öfter passiert
ganz viele kulturen haben sich überdehnt
die inka zum beispiel haben alles um
sich herum gerodet und dann war halt
irgendwann alles weg und dann waren sie
tot
also mussten aufgeben sind gestorben
verhungert und so weiter und so fort und
wir werden halt wir werden vielleicht
auch verhungern weil wir haben ja
gesehen diese hitze vernichtet die ernte
zu einem erheblichen teil
vielleicht wenn wir auch einfach einfach
an diesem hohen klima man darf nicht
vergessen über 37 grad also über unsere
körpertemperatur
es ist für uns verdammt schwierig ist
überhaupt auswahl also wenn die menschen
wirklich sterben wie die fliegen wenn
wir über 37 grad lufttemperatur haben
weil der körper es kaum noch hinkriegen
seine körpertemperatur zu halten wir
wissen aber ab einer bestimmten
temperatur gewinnen dann auch die
eiweiße die proteine bei uns im körper
und dann ist exitus und das kann uns bei
hohen temperaturen wenn man das nicht in
den griff kriegen auch passieren also
ist nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich eine
frage dazu gerade die schon ein bisschen
auf dem tisch liegt wo liegt denn die
richtige temperatur und wer legt sie
fest und wieso also die richtige
temperatur die hat sich einfach dadurch
ergeben dass es eine temperatur auf der
erde gibt und wir die evolution uns als
lebewesen produziert hat das heißt die
temperatur vor der industrialisierung
die also etwa weltweit 1 grad und jeden
deutschland als grafiker und niedriger
war ist für unsere spezies die richtige
temperatur deutlich darüber wird es
einfach schwierig und das kann man
natürlich nicht so auf den ort genau
sagen es gibt orte die werden jetzt auf
dauer unbewohnbar weil sie einfach zu
heiß werden
es gibt orte werden
roma war der meeresspiegel so stark
steigt und es kein wasser mehr gibt was
man trinken kann fidschi-inseln hast du
als beispiel genannt into valo und so
weiter und so fort
das ist so sind die unterschiedlichsten
plätze geben wo man einfach nicht mehr
leben kann eine flüchtlings bewegung
weil es auch dann nichts mehr zu essen
gibt also das ist ja auch pflanzen
bestimmte pflanzen können ab bestimmten
temperaturen nicht mehr oder auch ab
bestimmten wassermengen nicht mehr
existieren was wir hier gesehen haben
bis zu 40 prozent der ernte ist einfach
weggefallen das heißt wenn es hart auf
hart kommt gibt es einfach zu wenig zu
essen also man muss auch sagen dass ja
auch ein zusammenhang zwischen allem das
ist die temperatur
das ist die menge der menschen die hier
auf der erde lebt wir sind so viele wir
haben immer deutlich vor der jahresmitte
die ressourcen der erde verbrauchte
leuchten ob ich im schnitt so drei
irgendwo als diese menge an menschen zu
existieren den meeresspiegel ist noch ob
es klug bestimmte punkte dazu aber
richtig ist das was vor der
industrialisierung war weil es da noch
nicht vom menschen beeinflusst war und
damit war es das was die erde mieten
konnte man darf nicht vergessen es gibt
auch andere katastrophen die eintreten
können erdbeben die menschen töten
tsunamis nun kann ausbrüche und so
weiter und so fort
das können wir nicht verhindern aber es
geht ja darum etwas was wir selbst
verursacht haben was die situation noch
verschlimmert auf der erde
das wäre das
aufhalten können ist jetzt ist hier
gerade ein kommentar dazu von ralf
schmidt wir sind immer noch unter der
ideale temperaturen seit 2016 wird es
kälter
was meteorologen 2010 prognostizierten
ohne co2 aber mit sonne
bitte was naja das ist das also was die
sonne dass die sonne uns weniger würde
ich jetzt erstmal anzeichen dass sie ihr
hört sich für mich relativ unlogisch an
ohne co2 aber mit sondern als ich
verstehe es nicht so ganz
weil die temperaturen ja tatsächlich
gestiegen sind 1,1 und 1,4 in
deutschland das heißt dass es nicht
kälter sondern es ist wärmer geworden
was können wir tun hatten wir
das finde ich vielleicht das ganz
interessant wenn wir eine komplette
umstellung machen würde also von heute
auf morgen sagen okay jetzt gogreen weiß
ich nicht die ganze welt zieht mit ist
dann möglich noch den klimawandel wieder
einzudämmen oder in dem fall aufzuhalten
gehe ich immer stark von aus wie lange
würde es schätzungsweise dauern
also das ist die frage die wir mal
hatten mit dem punkt gegen sie irgendwo
schon klick punkte überschritten worden
wo ein sich selbst verstärkender prozess
angestoßen wurde das konnte zum beispiel
in der arktis wird passiert sein wo
inzwischen so viel eis weg ist dass es
viele dunkle flächen gibt es wird
weniger sonnenlicht reflektiert das
heißt die arktis wärmt sich von selber
auf wir haben die permafrosts geschichte
in temperaturen sind so hoch dass dort
ein gas entweicht das selber den
klimawandel beschleunigt methan und wir
wissen nicht objektiv punkte schon
erreicht haben oder nicht dieses ziel
1,5 oder den gehen wie man auf zwei grad
zu beschränken ist lediglich eine
hoffnung dass wir dann einen
galoppierenden klimawandel aufhalten
können wir wissen es aber nicht aber
natürlich ist die beste chancen erstes
das zu tun
dann müssen wir sehen was passiert
müssen über ein zwei jahrzehnte messen
was passiert währenddessen aber
vielleicht schon reagieren und co2 aus
der atmosphäre entziehen
vielleicht auch abschatten anderen
wirklich geo engineering techniken
anwenden um den klimawandel wieder
zurückzufahren
aber es ist halt wir haben wirklich
etwas losgetreten was wahnsinnig
schwierig ist das ist wie wenn man so
ein dominostein saal hat und einen tippt
man anderen ist es zu spät dann kann man
nichts mehr machen und wir wissen aber
nicht ob wir das schon getan haben oder
nicht aber wir haben auf jeden fall
etwas angestoßen was gar nicht gar nicht
gut ist und
es kann halt sein dass wir uns wie
anderen wirklich zerstören und dann muss
die räte sich wieder berappeln und wird
angespielt sie uns ihr vorbringen die
auch vielleicht auf einer wärmen erde
überleben können oder die dieser eiszeit
überleben können und dann wenn sie sich
wieder auf eine andere temperatur
gekommen ist wieder entwickeln können
aber es kann auch sein dass wir die
komplette er den bass verwüstet haben
und wenig mehr auf den boden bekommt
dann kann hier keiner überlegen eine
frage die auch gezielt zu dem was wir
glaube ich in der info karten haben zur
petition reicht eine petition oder muss
mehr getan werden also es muss
sicherlich mehr getan
das kann man kann man auf jeden fall
schon bejan braucht es eine neue
ökologische bewegung ist aufstehen eine
möglichkeit dafür
ja also ich denke das braucht so etwas
also so wie wir jetzt gegen nazis in
chemnitz aufstehen müssen wir auch für
die klimawende aufstehen und unbedingt
etwas tun um so mehr umso besser so wie
es jetzt geht vor allem wie wir auch
jetzt von der autoindustrie wirklich von
jedem autohersteller ich glaube das war
jeder in deutschland hat uns betrogen
hat uns autos untergeschoben die
menschen zu tausenden umbringen
ich warte auf den ersten mordprozess
gegen einen vorstand eines autokonzern
zwei tote sind dort im ort denn es hat
den bedingungen bin ich menschen aus
niederen motiven umbringen und ich
glaube die gewinnmaximierung eines
autokonzerns oder hat man die motive
dahinter waren ja die autos waren
einfach nicht schnell genug die ware
nicht dynamisch genug wir wollten
einfach kleinere autos produzieren dann
sich gesagt kommt machen wir das koste
es was es wolle und es hat halt einige
tausende leben gekostet und das ist
schon eine schreckliche katastrophe
und dass so etwas überhaupt möglich ist
und dass die autoindustrie hofft
gerettet zu werden das ist ein riesiges
problem
und es ist wirklich ein riesiges problem
weil da ja auch millionen arbeitsplätze
daran hängen und um millionen
arbeitsplätze zu schützen haben sie das
getan und damit eben genau das gegenteil
erreicht nämlich millionen arbeitsplätze
aufs spiel gesetzt und angela merkel hat
schon gesagt wir müssen unbedingt etwas
tun wie sie rechnet erst früher oder
später mit 300.000 arbeitslosen in
diesem bereich ja und das ist eine
katastrophe und gerade deshalb müssen
wir auch wir hängen hinten bei
elektroantrieben hinterher um selber
etwas tun es wichtig also fahrt mit der
bahn fahrt mit öffentliche
verkehrsmittel fahrrad und so weiter und
sofort fliegt weniger staat weniger
kreuzfahrtschiffe versucht einfach euren
ökologischen fußabdruck zu verringern
und das ist schon beispiel was wichtig
ist aber ich glaube wir brauchen
bewegung also wobei dies gibt sie im
moment so nicht geplant hieß es gibt die
grünen die man wählen kann
es gibt
auch viele anderen parteien die sich
inzwischen ich sage mal in going
geändert haben oder für grüne politik
auch stehen
ich will ja keine wahlempfehlung geben
aber man muss auf jeden fall etwas tun
und ansonsten ist es zu spät ja absolut
heute furchtbar ich fühle mich gerade so
ein bisschen an unserer anfangszeit
erinnert 2014 nämlich hier ist die frage
was hältst du von flugzeugen welche
zukünftigen aktmodelle wären dafür am
besten geeignet eventuell sogar mit
solar angetrieben wäre graf in eine gute
idee für die tigers ist ja einige fragen
was mich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen
erinnert hat war das mit solar
angetrieben ich glaube ich habe damals
einen blog artikel auch geschrieben über
eine weltumrundung die zwei männer
gemacht haben mit einem solarflugzeug
dann natürlich das flugzeug konnte nur
zwei drei herzen aber die haben das ja
meint sondern auch also für
verkehrsflugzeuge ist glaube ich
wahnsinnig schwer weil sie also das war
ja das flugzeug mit der weltumrundung
das flugzeug mit der band ono war hatte
er eine riesen spannweite hatte also
dementsprechend eine riesige fläche für
solarzellen
ich glaube wenn man das auf ein
verkehrsflugzeug mit hunderten
passagieren um rechnen würde müssen dass
ich sage mal zehn mal so groß seien die
flugzeuge heute sind was daran liegt
dass der wirkungsgrad von solarzellen
und der wird soweit ich das verfolgt
habe nicht deutlich steigen können sogar
20 prozent liegt also soviel energie
kann man gar nicht ausziehen und das ist
ein bisschen der kasus knaxus was ich
was ich interessant finde ist dass es
drohnen taxis gibt das könnte die
zukunft sein könnte auto könnte städte
entlasten weil die brauchen
sag mal wenn ich schon der einen ecke
von berlin zu anderen fliegen will kann
ich das in zehn minuten machen im
dritten taxi dann brauche ich nicht viel
ab und dafür das heißt so ein taxi
könnte vielleicht sogar eine stunde in
der luft sein das heißt zehn mal hin und
herfliegen in berlin zum beispiel das
könnte vielleicht sogar von ganzen tag
reichen oder ansonsten wechselkurs also
da kann ich mir zum beispiel so etwas
vorstellen dass es funktioniert
verkehrsflugzeuge schwierig aber man ist
ja sie sind intensiv an der entwicklung
und vielleicht klappt es ja auch ich
kann mir nur wenn ich heute selbst steht
sehe mit welcher power den abreden muss
um sein eigenes gewicht und das gewicht
der passagiere und das gepäck nach oben
zu bringen wie das mit strom
funktionieren soll
ich weiß es nicht also so wird auf jeden
fall nicht funktionieren da muss man
vielleicht umdenken und vielleicht
einfach wirklich weniger fliegen
wir müssen ja nicht schon ab
und wir haben heute moderne technologien
[Musik]
skype können wir wunderbar konferieren
und und man kann halt schon eine menge
machen
man muss vielleicht nicht immer durch
die gegend fliegen ja so denke ich mir
dass da wird es dann direkt auch noch
mal ein thema anschließend weil wir
können auch von fliegen sprechen diese
überlegene überlassen was wissen die was
wissen wir eigentlich über unsere
nachbar sternensysteme können wir dahin
fliegen gibt es vielleicht planeten die
der erde ähnlich sind und hier steht
auch noch dass wir ein paar
filmempfehlungen vielleicht auch geben
können
mir fällt da spontan auch was ein also
ich glaube 1 es gibt ein projekt das
breakthrough starship projekt womit man
zu proxima centauri fliegen will was er
inhaltlich jahre im moment von uns
entfernt das ist ein sternensystem was
übrigens auf unser sonnensystem
zusteuert aber das ist ein zeitläufen
die ähnlich unserer tage dauern da
braucht man ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz viele generationen von
uns bis dieses sternsystem hier sein
wird aber bikes da schickt soll es
glaube ich in mehreren jahrzehnten
schaffen
das ist eine ganz kleine sonden die mit
laserstrahlen beschleunigt werden
dadurch relativ schnell werden
das problem ist wenn sie dann bei
proxima centauri sind fliegen sie so
schnell vorbei dass sie nur ganz
sporadisch daten zurückschicken können
und das problem ist die dauern dann auch
wieder viereinhalb jahre bis sie bei uns
sind ja also das ist es hat man mit
einem raumschiff zu einem anderen
sternensystemen hinzukommen ist im
moment absolut unmöglich wir warten ja
alle auf die erfindung des web antreten
dass da gibt es entsprechende konzepte
warp antrieb ist dass das wir können ja
nicht schneller als das licht raum kann
sich aber schneller aus denen als sich
das universum dehnt sich schneller als
licht aus was man an der rotverschiebung
von licht sieht das zu uns kommt
das ist nur mit raum möglich und jetzt
ist die idee hey dann müssen wir den
raum verzehren um uns fortzubewegen und
wer weiß wenn das wirklich funktionieren
sollte wären wir in der lage mit einer
höheren geschwindigkeit als licht und
raum zu bewegen indem wir eben uns nicht
fortbewegen bei fortbewegen tut man sich
nur im raum sondern indem wir den raum
wörter und das ist der job antrieb und
ja man schauen also aber noch immer
nicht so was gibt die these also das ist
die geschichte von raumschiff enterprise
in dem moment wo wir uns befinden neben
andere zivilisationen kontakt mit uns
auf wenn sie sich nicht selber mit einem
klimawandel oder einer klimakatastrophe
zerstört haben wo wir gerade von
technologien auch noch mal sprechen
wie ist denn der aktuelle stand der
fusionstechnologie also die
fusionstechnologie wir haben ja in
frankreich den äther reaktor der gebaut
werden sollte das erste mal ein
dauerhaftes plasma erzeugen soll aus dem
ich glaube noch keine energie gewonnen
werden sollen aber das einfach schon mal
zeigt das prinzip funktioniert das ist
ein fass ohne boden muss man fast sagen
also das teurer aber im moment sehen sie
so aus als würde es tatsächlich auf
fertiggestellt werden
da sind weltweit
die nationen beteiligt also china
russland japan deutschland frankreich
usa glaube ich auch also ganz vielen
nationen sind daran beteiligt und diese
technik nach vorne zu treiben wenn die
steine exzellent greifswald da gibt es
ja einen forschungsreaktor der auch
immer besser funktioniert und es gibt ja
auch sehr einige alternative modelle die
jetzt nicht diese beiden modelle
funktionieren mit zwei unterschiedlichen
prinzipien eines placements das in einem
ring erzeugt wird und es gibt noch die
es gibt noch andere methoden wo es an
einen punkt erzeugt wird wo plasma
substanzen aufeinander geschossen werden
plasma zu erzeugen weiteren sofort die
deutlich preiswerter sind und
tatsächlich funktionieren könnte aber
wir wissen es noch nicht
schauen wir mal also vor allem das steht
nicht in den sternen sondern ja das
steht keine ahnung wo wir wissen es
nicht wie es klappen
man ist sich sicher das ist alles hin
haben wird weil dann haben wir die
energie der sonne hier auf der erde
das ist sie ist sehr umweltfreundlich
wenn im gegensatz zum atomkraftwerk ans
keinen gau geben
das schiff dient bericht das passt
zusammen ist einfach ende ausgehen würde
niemand schaltet es gibt nicht so stark
radioaktiven abfall also dass wir also
und zwar dramatisch weniger radioaktiv
ist zb der atomkraft ein riesiges
problem
wir haben bis heute noch nicht gelöst so
wie das solchen tun und es gibt ohne
ende schon atommüll auf der erde strahlt
und menschen umbringt das ist auch keine
gute technologie ich finde es schon mal
sehr interessant was ich eben recht viel
diskussion mittlerweile auftut
also es wird hier viel untereinander
gesprochen kurz einen mutig von hallo wo
sind jetzt der chat in den chat anzeigen
bayer die technik ja ich die technik
kurz hinein bauen mal wird nämlich dass
mit mir nicht ganz schwindelig
von diesen vielen kommentaren was ich
hasse es okay das wird lustig das
kriegen wir hin
[Musik]
jetzt hat so der mann
und wir haben ja hier auf dem kanal
eigene moody's dass nicht alle barrieren
lustiges feature so
anfrage habe ich noch in defense spielen
sonnenzyklen eine rolle in der
gegenwärtigen klima veränderungen
beeinflusst natürlich das wetter hier
aber nicht in dem maße wie ich die
klimaveränderung zu man muss sagen die
klimaveränderung sind halt eine globale
und zwar global nicht nur für die ganze
erde sondern auch eine veränderung für
eine sehr lange zeit raum und das ist
bei den ganzen sonnenaktivität natürlich
nicht der fall da gibt es für die werden
stärker die wir in schwächer aber die
werden alleine nicht in der lage einen
so dramatischen wandel einzuleiten wie
viren hier zurzeit haben und sie sind
auch wenn sie ihn zurück gehen nicht in
der lage diesen dramatischen wandel
aufzuhalten und sehen wenn ein großteil
der arktis oder des polymers eisfrei ist
dann etwas einfach dramatische
konsequenzen wenn die gletscher
zurückgehen wenn das wasser wärmer wird
und steigt es hat einfach dramatische
konsequenz in einem umfang dass diese
zyklischen veränderung bei weitem
übersteigt und mit denen haben wir
einmal gelebt die können auch mal für
ernste veränderung sorgen aber so kurzen
zeitraum dass sie nicht so etwas
anschieben können weil wir machen das
halt schon mehr als 100 jahre dass wir
den klimawandel anschieben und das hat
die erde
diese idee hat die sonne in diesem
umfang noch nie gemacht und es hat nicht
zu diesen erheblichen konsequenzen
geführt
natürlich wer hat auch eiszeiten kann
auch wiederkommen
aber das ist halt der große unterschied
das muss man auch einfach ich sag mal
philosophisch sehen ja wir können uns
nicht gegen wehren gegen die veränderung
die die erde mit macht ja und auch die
erde kann zu klimaveränderungen führen
und die sonne und das tut alles um uns
herum die vielleicht tätig sind aber es
selbst verursacht zu haben ist einfach
ein verbrechen an den nachfolgenden
generationen und wir haben damit auf
kosten dieser generation gelebt und das
finde ich persönlich nicht mehr alles
klappt dann vielleicht doch
sonnenaktivität rhein gesprungen ist der
klimawandel nicht vielmehr abhängig von
der sonnenaktivität als von co2 auf das
thema aber in dem fall also nochmal ganz
wichtig wirklich dass es so simpel wie
es ist die wissenschaft hat festgestellt
das eben nicht eingestellt ich weiß es
gibt studien die auch mal komplett
daneben sind es gibt wissenschaftler
genügen
aber es gibt dort hunderte und tausende
studien inzwischen die sich alle
gegenseitig bestätigen so eine große
wissenschaftliche verschwörung ohne
grund warum sollten sie es sie kein
wissenschaftler der in posen in der
position ist der schon mal ein job hat
muss dafür sorgen dass er seinen job
weil er hat den job schon also diese
logik ja die machen das alle um den job
zu erhalten ist quatsch der einmal an
der uni ist und professor ist ja auch
keinen job zu verrichten
außerdem jetzt noch andere jobs also das
ist also totaler humbug nein es ist nach
wissenschaftlichen prinzipien gearbeitet
worden dass es nach dem prinzip warum
gibt es warum wird es heißer wer ist
verantwortlich co2 oder komplett co2 aus
dem schornstein
es gibt keine andere quelle ganz simple
wissenschaftliche forschung
es ist eigentlich super einfach so jetzt
hab ich wirklich steuern so langsam auf
das ende genau wir wollten so um 18 uhr
919 fläche ungefähr dass ich hätte es
doch ganz kurz er ist eine frage müssen
wir dann im winter nicht mehr so frieren
der winter steht ja dann bald wieder
jahren im winter nicht frieren also das
muss man feststellen ich war vor 20
jahren mal hier in berlin da sind mir
echt die füße abgefroren und das habe
ich hier nicht mehr erlebt seitdem ich
hier wohne seit ein paar jahren die
winter waren hier sehr mild und gewinn
bild für berlin eine eigene müssen
weniger frieren im winter und mehr
schützen sommer im großen und ganzen
muss man sagen es könnte durchaus auch
viel kältere winter gehen
es könnte laut sommer geben klima ist
eben nicht wetter aber im schnitt wird
wärmer im winter von dem sommer
ja und jetzt finde ich kann es nur ganz
kurz weil auch gerade die frage
aufkommen wie kommt man dann diese
images das darfst du noch einmal ganz
kurz sagen also die monkees die bekommt
er jeder kannte den modus nutzen wenn er
mitglied wird und wir machen noch einige
dazu und die kann man dann hier im live
chat nutzen ich kann ja nochmal
abschießen was ihm eine sekunde genau
hier jung ist zum beispiel der könnte
jetzt eine solche motive benutzen weil
er mitglied ist und was mache ich denn
noch hier ich mache mal hier den noch
und dann kann ich nochmal den machen
weil manchmal denke ich auch nach und
dann kann ich mal ganz traurig sein über
die klimaskeptiker
und dann kann ich was ist das auch jetzt
mal ganz kurz ruhe achtung ein
so haben wir jetzt noch und hier noch
ich kann auch ein küsschen geben achtung
jetzt kommt ein bisschen so ach da hat
ja jemand alle reingeschrieben vielen
dank vielen dank vielen dank das kann
man alles als mitglied markt und das ist
übrigens eine aktion die wir machen die
wir dann umso mehr mitmachen umso toller
wert
ihr könnt mit geht auf dem kanal werden
unter diesem video müsste ein button
sein es kommt um das betriebssystem an
sonst geht man den rechner mitglied
werden für einen geringen beitrag im
monat unterstützt er uns und wir
schalten um so mehr kanal mitglieder wir
haben vor um so mehr videos die werbung
ab in dieser woche wird es das erste
video ohne werbung geben und das ziel
der ein komplett werbefreies video dank
eurer unterstützung das finde ich ganz
toll weil ich finde dass ist die werbung
die nervt wir machen das ja auch auf
whatsapp da gibt es unter den videos
links manchmal werbung aber da kriegt
dann den videolink in erster linie und
ich hoffe dass euch ein text der dann
drunter noch schäden nicht all zu sehr
nervt freeroll glaube ich tot ist das
dauert eine weile bis dann endlich das
video losgeht und wir können halt über
mitglieder auf eine andere art geld zum
geldverdienen im bekommt livestreams
extra gleich machen wir den noch im
nachhinein für die mitglieder wenn ich
mal gespannt dass er das wird das müssen
wir so fragen ob
die mit die wir jetzt noch lust haben
jetzt direkt aus anzuschließen oder ob
den neuen termin ausmachen
lasst uns man irgendwann schließen
lassen können sie nicht fragen nein wir
bieten einfach es wird ja hoffentlich
nicht so schwierig sein denn wir machen
natürlich auch wir machen noch extra -
wir werden ein sehr lustiges extra video
jetzt in diesen tagen machen eben es
gibt extra live streams und das ein oder
andere und ihr könnt uns somit auch auf
paefgen unterstützen da gibt es sogar
ein buch und persönliche treffen und so
weiter und so fort
ja und ich finde es besser wenn wir halt
irgendwann mal ohne werbung existieren
könnten das wäre super
und weil das sind wichtige themen und da
muss ich unbedingt immer werbung dafür
laufen ja aber wenn es nicht genug mit
blumen gibt es auch nicht schlimm
dann machen wir weiter mit werbung aber
umso mehr es gibt die das unterstützen
um so besser ist es ich danke wird nicht
allen es werden immer mehr
das ist wirklich ganz ganz toll ich
freue mich riesig hätte nie gedacht dass
er so schnell schon werbung abschalten
können wobei die idee mit dem werbung
abschalten ist mir echt erst später
gekommen
ich dachte mir hey das ist doch mal ein
richtig guter grund um das zu machen
weil werbung nervt und und übrigens noch
viele fragen warum muss denn die werbung
sein also alle die hier arbeiten nicht
nur ich auch ein windschott karte hinter
der kamera neben alles philippe wir
wollen ab und zu mal was essen und auch
wohnen und das kostet geld und ganz
ehrlich man verdient hier das weißt du
glaub ich den situation gesprochen mit
kanälen mit dieser reichweite jetzt
nicht so viel dass man im geld schwimmen
kann bei weitem nicht und deswegen
brauchen wir halt einnahmen um das
überhaupt machen zu können und um so
mehr dass ohne werbung geht umso besser
wenn das smartphone dann mache ich so
eine ganz große anzahl und zwar posten
wir gleich noch mal einen neuen live
stream link dann in whatsapp und in die
community hat nur für die mitglieder und
bei petrom kommt der neue link dann auch
das heißt für die mitglieder schließen
wir jetzt direkt an einen livestream
noch an da könnt ihr auch noch mal in
kleinerer runde fragen stellen und wir
sprechen ja noch so ein bisschen und
eure meinung jetzt wurden die meinung
interessiert
der chat auch etwas langsamer genau über
also bis dann
bis dann
bleibt dran super so und jetzt
[Musik]